[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصف الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من اندرمان على وقع
معارك ضاريه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
وهذه الصور من البيت الابيض وتصريحات
لمنسقه الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي يقول فيها انه تم
تزويد اوكرانيا بالقذائف العنقوديه لتعويض
النقص الحاصل في مخزونات بعض القذائف والى
موسكو حيث جاء الرد على لسان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بقوله ان روسيا
لديها مخزون كاف من القنابل العنقوديه
وتحتفظ بحق استخدامها اذا تم استخدامه
ذخيره مماثله ضد القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
وسط معارك على جبهات عده بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه تقول انها باتت في
موقف دفاعيا في خاركاز وتلوح بمهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه باسلحه محليه
بوتين يعتبر ان الجيش الاوكراني لم يحرز
اي تقدم في هجومه المضاد ويلوح باستخدام
ذخائر عنقوديه في حال استخدام الذخائر
الامريكيه
دون تمديد او التوافق على اي بديل انتهاء
العمل باتفاقيه الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
البحر الاسود خلال ساعات اخر سفينه تغادر
ميناء اوديسا الاوكراني بموجب الاتفاق
الكريم
واتصالات دوليه لتمديد العمل بالاتفاق
في ام درمان والخرطوم وشمال غربي نيالا
معارك عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع ووسط دعوات لتنسيق المسارات
وجهود الراميه لتسويه الازمه وفد الجيش
السوداني يعود الى جده والدعم السريع يقول
انه مستعد لسناف التفاوض
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا توقيع اتفاق بين تونس
والاتحاد الاوروبي للحد من تدفق طالبي
اللجوء عبر المتوسط مقابل برنامج مساعدات
ماليه وحوافز اقتصاديه الاتفاق اطلق عليه
اسم الشراكه الاستراتيجيه والشامله
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما
الهدف الابرز من مذكره التفاهم التونسيه
الاوروبيه الموقعه اليوم جاءت النتائج
كالتالي
13% قالوا ان الهدف هو مساعده تونس في
الخروج من ازمتها الاقتصاديه بينما راى
87% ان مذكره التفاهم هي لحمايه الدول
الاوروبيه من موجات طالب اللجوء
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
ومتابعه لردود الفعل بشان مذكره التفاهم
الاوروبيه التونسيه نناقش في الحصاد لاحقا
مع ضيفين تونسيين مضمون المذكره والطرف
الاكثر استفاده من بنودها خصوصا ما يتعلق
بملف طالب اللجوء
[موسيقى]
خط التماس بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني
لا يتحرك بشكل ملحوظ منذ سيطره روسيا على
ضخمه وبات واضحا ان الهجوم المضاد لا يسير
كما كان مخططا له بحسب رئاسه الاوكرانيه
رغم استمرار كييف باستهداف مناطق تسيطر
عليها روسيا ابرزها شبه جزيره القرم
وسيفاستوبول المدينه التي تستضيف اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي اضافه الى ضرب مناطق
في العمق الروسي وهو تكتيك لوح به قائد
الجيش الاوكراني في حديث مع صحيفه واشنطن
بوست
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز قالت ان الجيش
الاوكراني خسيرا نحو 20% من عتاده العسكري
خلال الاسبوعين الاولين من الهجوم المضاد
الذي بداه في الرابع من يونيو الماضي وان
الخسائر شملت معدات ودبابات ونقلات جند
مدرعه غربيه الصنع وتضيف الصحيفه ان حقول
الالغام هي العائق الاهم امام اي تقدم
اوكراني حيث عمد الجيش الروسي الى زرع
الغام مضاده للافراد والمدرعات بعمق
يتراوح بين خمسه و16 كيلومترا قرب معاقله
الرئيسي
الخسائر وضعت الجيش الاوكرانيه في موقف
دفاعي لاسيما على الجبهه الشرقيه بحسب
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
بينما قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ان جميع محاولات اوكرانيا اختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه خلال الهجوم المضاد باءت بالفشل
هذه العوامل دفعت القوات الاوكرانيه الى
تغيير تكتيكاتها للحد من خسائرها وركزت
على استخدام المدفعيه والصواريخ بعيده
المدى واعتماد مجموعات هجوميه تكتيكيه من
جنود المشاه بدلا من اللجوء الى توغل بري
واسع لتفادي الدخول في حقول الالغام
والاشتباك المباشر مع الجيش الروسي وضمن
التكتيكات الميدانيه تبرز اهميه القنابل
العنقوديه التي قد تكون اداه فعاله ضد
تقدم القوات الروسيه والاستهداف الخنادق
والتحصينات الروسيه بحسب ما كشفت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست نقلا عن الكانتاكون في وقت
تؤكد موسكو انها لم تلجا بعد الى ذخائر
العم لكنها تحتفظ بحقها في استخدامها متى
فعلت اوكرانيا بحسب الرئيس الروسي
لدى روسيا مخزون كاف من مختلف انواع
القنابل العنقوديه وحتى اللحظه لم نستخدمه
اذ لم تكن هناك ضروره لذلك ولكن اذا
استخدموها ضدنا فسنحتفظ بحق الرد بالمثل
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سولفن
اعلن ان تزويد كييف بالذخائر العنقوديه
ياتي لتغطيه النقص في مخزونات ذخائر من
عيار
155 ملم
وبحسب سالب فان واشنطن اعطت ايضا الضوء
الاخضر للاوروبيين لبدء تدريب الاوكرانيين
على طائرات اف 16
فاوكرانيا ومنذ عده اشهر تطالب حلفاءها
بتزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16 لتغطيه النقص في
انظمه الدفاع الجوي وللايجاد بعض التوازن
في قدرات سلاح الجو الاوكراني مقارنه
بالقوه الجويه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
وفي الداخل الروسي قال حاكم مقاطعه
الروسيه ان امراه قتلت واصيب اخرون في قصف
اوكراني استهدف السوق المركزي في منطقه
شبكينيو كما تضررت واجهات محال تجاريه في
المنطقه وفق حاكم المقاطعه فان بيلجورود
تعرضت لقصف اوكراني بنحو 90 قذيفه خلال
ساعات الاربعاء والعشرين الماضيه بحسب
قوله
ينضم الينا من مدينه كانسيس المدير السابق
لمكتب روسيا في البنتاجون ومعنا من موسكو
المحلل العسكري فيكتور مرحبا بكما سنبدا
معك سيد فيكتور الم يتسرع الرئيس الروسي
بالحكم من الان على الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني بانه فشل
كلا لم يستعجل لان القوات
الاوكرانيه لم تستطع ولا من لمره واحده ان
تصل لخطوط الدفاع الاولى منذ شهر وخسروا
حوالي 20 الف جندي وحوالي
1500 وحده عسكريه بما فيها المسيرات
والدبابات الفرنسيه والالمانيه
والبريطانيه والكثير من المعدات المدرعه
مثل بريدلي واسترايكر ولذلك هذه لوحه
موضوعيه والغربيين انفسهم يعترفون بهذا
والولايات المتحده تؤكد على هذه الارقام
ليس بوتين وحده من يقول ان الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني فشل حتى الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قبل
ايام قليله اعترفت بانه لم يحقق النتيجه
المرجوه ماذا يحصل لماذا باعتقادك
اعتقد اننا نحتاج الى نظره او صعف ما زال
من السابق لاوانه ان نقول ان الهجوم
المضاد قد فشل بالطبع هو ابطا مما كان
يوده
الاوكرانيون ويستغرق زمن اطول لكن على
نطاق الاوسع الاوكرانيون لا يحققون تقدما
ويسيطرون على الاراضي ويثبتون ان الروس
ليسوا قادرين على شان ايه هجمات مضاده
مهمه وسنرى على مدى الاشهر القادمه هجمات
وهجمات مضاده ربما قد يستطيعون الاوكرانين
ان يوقفوا الهجوم ويعيد تنظيمهم لكن لا
نستطيع ان نقول ان الهجوم قد فشد بالكامل
من اين يثبتون ما تقوله حتى اليوم نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول نحن في موقع
الدفاع اصبح اصبحت قواتنا في موقع الدفاع
لم يستطيعوا حتى الان ان يخرجوا روسيا من
المناطق التي تحتلها في اوكرانيا
تاكيد
خط المواجهه طويل جدا وربما هناك قتال على
مدى خط جبهه 600 كيلومتر لذلك ليس من
الغرابه الاوكرانيين في اماكن من الجبل
يتخذون مواقف دفاعيه وفي اماكن اخرى
يتقدمون عليهما ان يحافظ على قدراتنا
القتاليه ليستخدموها هنا وهناك لاحداث
اختراقات هذا ليس من القبيل المفاجاه ولا
هو دليل على ان الهجوم المضاد لقد فشل
فيكتور لتفكن
الان ستدخل الى المعركه القنابل العنقوديه
هناك اتفاق دفاع مشترك مع الناتو بموجبه
ستحصل اوكرانيا على المزيد من الاسلحه
هناك ربما في الاشهر القادمه سته عشر كل
ذلك الن يكون من شانه ان يغير في
المعادلات على الارض
اولا الاف سته عشر لن تحصل عليها اوكرانيا
لان لانه ليس من الكافيه تدريب الطيارين
يجب ايضا ان يتعلموا استراتيجيه المعارك
الجويه عدا عن ذلك هناك بنيه تحتيه من
المطارات العسكريه الخاصه مع الرادارات
والابراج
وانظمه رادريه سوف تخدم تساعد
الطيارات على العوده
ومحطات لتصليح وايضا مصانع لقطع الغيار
ومستودعات للذخيره وكثير من الامور الاخرى
لذلك الطائره بحد ذاتها هي لا شيء لن يكون
هناك مكان للانطلاق او العوده لذلك
اذا قاموا بانشاء مثل هذه
المطارات من السهل على روسيا ان تجده
وتدبره وتدمره ولديها الكثير من الصواريخ
لهذا واي شيء سوف يبنى من هذا
المثال سوف ندمره خاصه وان الطيران الروسي
هو من يفرض السيطره على الاجواء حتى الان
الطائرات الاف سته عشر للاسف سوف تكون احد
المعدات الغربيه التي سوف يتم تدميرها انت
ربما تشاهد هذه الهجمات التي تطال
بالجورود وتحدث اضرارا كبيره وهذا التهديد
الاوكراني بنقل المعركه الى داخل روسيا
هل سوف ينقل
المعركه الى الاراضي الروسيه قد يقوم
باعمال ارهابيه ولكنهم لن يستطيعوا ان
يقوموا بهجمات على الاراضي الروسيه ليس
لديهم اي امكانيات وهم يتبعون الخطط
الامريكيه وخطط الناتو ولم يسبق لهذه
الدول ان يخترقوا اي خطوط دفاع ولم
يحاربوا مع عدو يساويهم بالقدرات والقوه
طالما حاربوا
الاعداء الضعفاء لن يستطيعوا ان يحاربوا
روسيا اما انهم يقوموا بالهجوم على
نعم هناك عمليات ارهابيه ولكنها يتم
ايقافها وتقوم القوات الشيشانيه بالرد على
هذه الهجمات لانهم هم من يدافعون عن
الحدود في بغداد
كيف ستتعامل الولايات واحده مع هذه
التهديدات الاوكرانيه بنقل المعركه بشكل
علني نقل بعض العمليات التي تقوم بها ونقل
المعركه الى روسيا كما يقول مسؤولون
اوكرانيون خصوصا ان الولايات المتحده
تحاول تجنب اي مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا
بالاسلحه الامريكيه لما قد يجره ذلك
بماذا كما تعلمون نفس الوقت المتحده
بالتاكيد لا تشجعوا الاوكرانيين لشنه
هجمات طويله المدى على روسيا واحدى
المحاجزات التي تقف ضد تزويد اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ بعيده ماذا هو ان تستخدم بهذه
الطريقه مع ذلك نقول ان من حقي اوكرانيا
الكامل مهاجمه القوات الروسيه في هذا
الجانب من الحدود في اوكرانيا او في جانبي
داخل اراضي الروسيه لاضعافها القوات هم
قاموا بذلك عده مرات وهم اذا ما قرروا
القيامه بذلك باسلحتهم الخاصه سنرى وننتظر
ماذا يحدث لذلك باسلحه التي يقدمها الغرب
وتقدمها الولايات المتحده
انا لست متاكدا حقيقه من ان هذا الامر هو
شيء تريد الوقت المتحده له ان يحدث
بالتاكيد الوقت المتحده ستتفهموا حق
اوكرانيا
القانوني وضمن قوانين الحظ هم ضمن حقوقهم
ان يقوم ذلك لكنني اشك في ان ذلك سيحدث
لان الواتس المتحده واوكرانيا متفقان على
عدم استخدامها الاسلحه التي تزودها امريكا
لمهاجمه روسيا داخل اراضيها شكرا لك مع
الدمدير السابق لمكتب روسيا في البانتاجون
من مدينه كانسيس وشكرا للسيد فيكتور من
موسكو المحلل العسكري اذا من العاصمه
الروسيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اجواء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فقد غادرت اليوم اخر سفينه ميناء اوديسا
الاوكراني بموجب اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود الذي ترعاه
الامم المتحده وذلك قبل موعد انقضاء سريان
الاتفاق ولم توافق روسيا على تسجيل اي سفن
جديده منذ 27 من الشهر الماضي وسينتهي اجل
الاتفاق غدا الاثنين الا اذا وافقت موسكو
على تمديده وقال متحدث باسم الامم المتحده
ان الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بوتياريش ينتظر ردا من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على مقترح لتمديد الاتفاق
وحسب الكريم فان بوتين اخبر رئيس جنوب
افريقيا في اتصال هاتفي ان الالتزامات
بتذليل عقبات تواجه صادرات الاغذيه
والاسمده الروسيه لم يتم الوفاء بها بعد
الاتفاق الوحيد الجامع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بعد ان فرقتهما الحرب سينتهي
بانتهاء يوم السابع عشر من تموز يوليو انه
اتفاق نقل الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود حتى
الان الجانب الروسي هو من لا يرغب في
تمديد الاتفاق فالرئيس الروسي يرى ان
الاتفاق عجز عن تلبيه مطالب بلاده وهي ان
تسير عمليه التصدير الحبوب والاسمده
الروسيه بسلاسه بعد ازاله او تخفيف
العقوبات المفروضه بالنظر الى ان الحبوب
الاوكرانيه نقلت عبر البحر الاسود مع بدء
سريان الاتفاق
المسؤولون الروس اكدوا ايضا ان الباب
مفتوح لاعاده تفعيل الاتفاق انت حققت
مطالبهم وعلى هذا تستمر جهود اقليميه
ودوليه لاعاده العمل بالاتفاق ومنها تركيا
الوسيط في ابرام الاتفاق بدايه والامم
المتحده المشرفه على توقيعه وتنفيذه
وبانتظار اعلان الروس رسميا عدم تمديد
الاتفاق او عكس ذلك فان شبح المجاعه وازمه
خصوصا القمح والذره عاد ليخيم على ملايين
المحتاجين لتلك الحبوب حول العالم وتحدثت
وكاله بلومبيرج عن ارتفاع في قيمه العقود
الاجله للقمح والذره فالاتفاق اتاح تصدير
نحو ثلاثه وثلاثين مليون طن من الحبوب منذ
بدء تنفيذه مطلع اب اغسطس عام 2022
الكميه الكبيره هذه عادت بالنفع على 45
دوله مثل الصين واسبانيا وتركيا
كما تمكن برنامج الاغذيه العالميه من
توفير 725 الف طن من القمح لدول تعيش
ازمات مثل افغانستان واثيوبيا وكينيا
والصومال والسودان واليمن فهل سيعود العمل
بالاتفاق ام ان حاله الجمود في اي تقارب
روسيا الاوكراني ستغلق المنافذ عليه ايضا
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث تحتدم المعارك في ولايه
الخرطوم فقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي
في جارات قويه ومتتاليه جنوبيه مدينه ام
درمان وبعيدا عن الخرطوم دارت معارك عنيفه
في مدينه كاس شمال غربي نيالا بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على الصعيد
السياسي شدد رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
على ضروره تنسيق الجهود الدوليه لحل
الازمه في السودان
يوميات السودان في اول ايام الشهر الرابع
من الاقتتال هيمن عليها نشاط سلاح الجو
السوداني في العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاث
فصباحا غاره الطائرات الحربيه على تجمعات
للدعم السريع في حي الجريف شرقي النيل ثم
قصفت مقاتلات سلاح الجو لاحقا محله بده
غربيه ام درمان
وبينما ردت قوات الدعم السريع على الغارات
الجويه باستخدام المضادات الارضيه اعلن
الجيش السوداني ان مسيرات تابعه للدعم
السريع قصفت مقر السلاح الطبي بامدرمان
ايضا كما اتهم الجيش في بيان ما سماها
الميليشيا المتمرده بقصف مستشفى علياء
التخصصي بام درمان ما ادى حسب البيان الى
اصابه سيده مريضه والحاق اضرار ضخمه بمركز
غسيل الكلى والعنايه المكثفه وغرفه
العمليات
القتال احتدم ايضا في غرب البلاد حيث شهدت
مدينه كاس شمال غرب نيالا عاصمه ولايه
جنوب دارفور اشتباكات عنيفه بمختلف انواع
الاسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع التي اعلنت في بيان صحفي انها
سيطرت على قياده اللواء الحادي والستين في
كاس وانها اثرت قائد القوه العسكريه
وثلاثين من افراد القوه كما استولت على
اسلحه بينها عربات قتال ومدافع وذخائر
وبينما يتدهور المشهد العسكري واكثر منه
الوضع الانساني في كل مناطق السودان تظل
المبادرات السياسيه على تعدد منابرها
عاجزه عن كبح جماح المتحاربين ولو بهدنه
انسانيه مؤقته فمحاولات منظمه الايجاد بدت
في حكم المنهاره بعد رفض الحكومه
السودانيه تراس الرئيس الكيني للجنه
الرباعيه المنبثقه عنها ومع ذلك يصر
الاتحاد الافريقي على مواصله دوره في
الازمه السودانيه ارموني زينوفي
حشدت الازمه السودانيه الخطيره جهودنا
بشكل مكثف مع منظمه ايجاد بتنسيق خرائط
الطريق التي وضعناها لوقف الاعمال
العدائيه وتعبئه المساعدات الانسانيه
واشراك السودانيين في حوار سياسي شامل
لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه انتقاليه قادره على
تنفيذ خطه اقتصاديه طارئه وببرنامج انساني
وامني وفيما لا تجد دعوات قمه دول جوار
السودان التي انعقدت الخميس في مصر حتى
الان اذان صاغيه من طرفي النزاع رغم
ترحيبهما ببيانها الختامي يبدو منبر جده
في طور استئناف جهوده فالجيش السوداني
اعاد ارسال ممثله الى هناك بعد ان علق
مشاركته في تلك المفاوضات اواخر شهر مايو
الماضي عضو مجلس السياده شمس الدين
الكباشي اكد للجزيره ان المجلس منفتح على
اي مبادره جاده لوقف الحرب في اطار
المحافظه على سياده السودان
ومؤسساته وتلك تصريحات وصفها بيان من
الدعم السريع بالايجابيه
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس الدكتور
محمد تورشين الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون
الافريقيه دكتور محمد ماذا يعني استمرار
احتدام المعارك على الارض رغم اللغه
الايجابيه التي ابتسمت بها تصريحات
الطرفين بالامس
وتعهدت بالعوده الى المفاوضات في جده
في البلد تحيه لك ولكل الساده المشاهدين
الكرام يمكن قراءه ذلك في سياقين السياق
الاول بانه ما زالت رغبه طرف الصراع الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السرب ان يكون الحسم
العسكريا حاضرا في كل التدابير والخطط
العسكريه بان يكون النصر والحزم العسكري
في الاتجاه الاخر يمكن قراءتها في اتجاه
اخر بان هنالك ضغوطات مورثه هنالك
اجتماعات مكثفه كانت في الايام الماضيه
بحضور نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السيد مالك
عقار وواضع اعضاء البيع في الدبلوماسيه في
السودانيه في اثيوبيا وكذلك قيادات من
الدعم السريع يبدو ان هذه الضغوطات اتت
بثمارها من خلال التصريحات
نبدا نسميها انها معتدله من السيد شمس
الدين كباشي ومعلوم شمس الدين كباشي من
صخور القوات المسلحه السودانيه وهو الذي
بدا الخلاف او الذي ابدع ملاحظاته حول
الدعم السريع ومسيرته منذ ايام الايام
الفتره الانتقاليه فانا في تقديري هذه
ايضا الجزيه ربما في اطار تحسين الموقف
التفاوضي لا يصير من المتوقع ان تمتلك
جولات جديده للمباحثات وربما هذه الجولات
تناقش قضايا سياسيه واستقبال الفتره
الانتقاليه والعوده الى
ماذا نعرف عن هذه
المويه التي يمكن ان تناقشها هل نتوقع
هدنه جديده فقط عند هذا الحد في ضوء ما
كان قاله سابقا الجيش وانسحابه من
المفاوضات التي كانت جاريه وما الى هنالك
ام نحن نتحدث في هذه المرحله عن حل جذري
لما يحدث
ومن المعلوم ان المباحث الجلده في في
السابق كانت فقط تركز على الجوانب
الانسانيه وكل الهدن التي تم اطلاقها
الغرض منها فتح المسارات
لايصال المساعدات للمدنيين وما الى ذلك
لكن من خلال التصريحات وكثير من التسريبات
التي صدرت مؤخرا من الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع من المتوقع ان تكون مباحث الجده في
هذا التوقيت بالاخص تختلف تماما عن
الماضيه ربما تناقش قضايا منها وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار فضلا عن ذلك العوده الى
الحكومه الانتقاليه وهذا الامر ايضا اشار
له امس شمس الدين كباشي بتصريحه وكذلك من
قبل السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان وحتى مالك
عقار في كل تصريحاته فانا في تقديري يبدو
الان التحدي مرهون على الوساطه في تحديد
الاجهزه التفاوضيه بحيث اننا في تقدير
الحرب هي ليست غايه انما هدف الغايه
متمثلين واحد
في السابق كان الماخذ على الطرفين السعودي
والامريكي بانهما لم يمارسا ضغوطا كافيه
على الطرفين
المتحاربين من اجل حملهما على الدخول في
مفاوضات جديه هل تعتقد ان هذه المره ستكون
الامور مختلفه
انا في تقدير الله الجانب السعودي
الامريكي يمارسوا ضغوطات على طرفيه الصراع
بالقدره المستطاع لكن هنالك جزئيه اخرى
انه طرفيه الصراع لم تتبلور الظروف
الماثره لديهم للتوصل الى قناعات راسها
بضروره ان تكون هنالك مباحثات
وتفاوضات في في جده بحيث انه كان كله طرف
يعول على ان يكون الحسم العسكري هو الخيار
الامثل الاوحد لذا انا في تقدير الان وبعض
مرور ثلاثه اشهر ونحن الان في الشهر
الرابع يبدو ان موازين القوى لم تتغير
كثيرا كل الطرف ما زال يمتلك عناصر قوه
كامله وهذا ما يسمى في توازن القوى وتوازن
الضعف فبالتالي هذا العنصر ربما جعل
القيادات العسكريه للطرفين وكذلك ادراك
بان ينبغي ان تكون هنالك تسويه لاسيه اذا
كانت التسويه تحقق الهدف المنشود وهو ان
يكون جيش واحد موحد لاستكمال للفتره
الانتقاليه ومن بعض الخضوع لعمليه
الانتخابيه لكن الان التحدي بيكمل هل الان
بعض ثلاثه
شهور من المواجهات العسكريه هل الظروف
الناضجه تماما وكل طرف قادر
من شانها الوصول الى تفاهمات ام ماذا يقول
الطرف يتمسك برؤيته المرتبطه بان تكون
فتره دمج الدعم السريع في الجيش فتره
عامين او
اشكرك من باريس الدكتور محمد طورشنا
الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره ان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انسحب من مدينه بيت لحم بعد
اعتقاله ثلاثه شبان مشتبه بهم بتنفيذ
عمليه اطلاق نار عند مدخل مستوطنه تقوع
جنوب مدينه بيت لحم جنوبيه الضفه الغربيه
وافاد جيش الاحتلال في بيان عسكري بان
قوات من وحده كوماندوس خاصه بالتعاون مع
وحده الاستخبارات في جهاز الامن العام
الاسرائيلي الشباك اقتحمت مدينه بيت لحم
واعتقلت شبان الثلاثه وصادرت مركبه
بداخلها بندقيه من نوع ام 16
وكانت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلنت
اصابه ثلاثه مستوطنين بجروح في اطلاق نار
استهدفهم على مفرق تقوع جنوب بيت لحم وحسب
مصادر جيش الاحتلال فان النيران اطلقت على
المستوطنين من داخل سياره لاذت بالفرار من
المكان ودفع جيش الاحتلال بتعزيزات واغلق
كافه الشوارع في المنطقه وباشر عمليه
التمشيط واسعه بحثا عن المنفذين
ونبقى في الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث قالت
مصادر في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي للجزيره ان
اجهزه امن سلطه الفلسطينيه شنت اليوم
الاحد حمله اعتقالات واسعه استهدفت كوادر
من الحركه في بلده جبع بمحافظه جنين شملت
نشطاء بارزين منهم عبد حمامره ومحمد
علاونه ومحمد ملايشه ومؤمن
فشافشه وعماد خليله هذا وصفت الحركه حمله
الاعتقالات بانها جريمه مرفوضه وطنيا
واخلاقيا بحق الشعب ومقاومته على حد
تعبيرها كما قالت الحركه ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه رفضت الافراج عن نشطاء من
مقاومي سرايا القدس كانت اعتقلتهم منذ
ايام هذا ولم يصدر حتى الان اي تعليق من
السلطه الفلسطينيه بشان حمله الاعتقالات
بحق نشطاء الجهاد الاسلامي
وقد اطلقت اجهزه الامن الفلسطينيه سراح
الصحفي عقيل عواوده بعد احتجازه لدى جهاز
الامن الوقائي في بيتونيا منذ مساء الخميس
الماضي وكانت المحكمه قررت اليوم الافراج
عنه بكفاله شخصيه بعد رفض طلب تقدمت بان
النيابه العمل لتمديد توقيفه لخمسه عشر
يوما اضافيا لاستكمال اجراءات التحقيق
وكان الجهاز الامن الوقائي في رام الله قد
اعتقل عواوده بعد نشره مقطع فيديو عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينتقل فيه حديثا
للناطق باسم الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه
نفى فيه وجود اعتقالات سياسيه في الضفه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث اعلن رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
مارك روتي ان الاتحاد الاوروبي توصل الى
اتفاق مع تونس لوقف الهجره غير النظاميه
مقابل مساعدات اقتصاديه من جهتها دعت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل الى تعزيز
الشراكه مع تونس في مجال محاربه تهريب
البشر
سنعمل بشكل تشاركي من اجل بناء اقتصاد
تونسي قوي اكثر تحملا للصدمات مستعدون
لمساعده تونس عن طريق حشد الدعم المالي
وخاصه من خلال القمه التي ستعقد نحن في
حاجه الى تعاون اكبر في مجال الهجره ويجب
ان نحارب المهربين وتجار البشر ولذلك يجب
ان نعزز شركتنا مع تونس في مجال محاربه
التهريب ومن اجل هذا سنوفر ميزانيه لقيمه
100 مليون يورو
وكان الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد قال في
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع قاده اوروبيين في
تونس ان هناك حاجه ماسه لاتفاق جمعي بشان
الهجره غير النظاميه واتهم بعض المنظمات
بالاكتفاء بالبيانات دون تقديم دعم حقيقي
للمهاجرين غير النظاميين
وما اشد حاجتنا اليوم
الى اتفاق جماعي حول الهجره غير الانسانيه
وحول عمليات التهجير التي تقف وراءها
شبكات اجراميه
الشعب التونسي
لهؤلاء المهاجرين المهجرين
كل ما كل ما يمكن تقديمه
بسخاء غير محدود
في حين ان عديد المنظمات التي من المفترض
ان تقوم بدورها
بدورها الانساني
لم تتحرك الا عن طريق البيانات
معنى من تونس احمد الهمامي المتحدث الرسمي
باسم تحالف احرار ومن تونس ايضا ينضم
الينا مراد اليعقوبي الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد احمد الهمامي ما
تقييمك لهذا الاتفاق
شكرا لكم ولكل ضيوفك وكل مشاهديك الاتفاق
اليوم كان منت كما قلنا كل التونسيين
ينتظرون هذا الاتفاق لان هذا الاتفاق سيضع
الخطوط الكبيره والخطوط العريضه في مقاومه
الهجره الغير الانسانيه كما قال الرئيس
قيس سعيد والتي تقف ورائها عصابات
واجراميه فعلا الاتفاق اليوم لم يشمل فقط
الهجره وانما شمل عديد المجالات منها مجال
التعاون في مجال الاستثماري كذلك في مجال
الطاقي وهناك اتفاق واضح بين تونس وقاده
اوروبا على توجه جديد لتونس يكفينا من
الكلام وكانت رساله الرئيس قيس سعيد واضحه
يعني يكفيكم من الكلام فلنتوجه نحو الفعل
لمساعده
كل الناس التي تستحق المساعده حتى انتم
تندفون من هذا الم يكن الرئيس السعيد هو
من قال ان تونس لن تكون حارس حدود لاوروبا
عمليا هذا الاتفاق الا يحولها الى حارس
حدود
في حدودها من قبل وليس جديدا تحرس حدوده
وهذا واجب كل دوله ان تحرص حدودها البحريه
والبريه والجويه لكن هذا ليس بشيء جديد
وانما نحن لا كما قال السيد الرئيس لن
تكون ارض توطين تونس ستقوم بواجبها تشاهد
نفسها وتجاه شعبها وتجاه شركتها الدوليه
التاريخيه مع ايطاليا او فرنسا او هولندا
او الاتحاد الاوروبي بصفه عامه هناك شراكه
تاريخيه وليست جديده وانما لابد من مقاومه
الهجره ليس بطريقه كما قال سعيد في حراسه
الحدود فقط او بترحيل المهاجرين فقط لابد
من مشاريع استثماريه في تلك البلدان حتى
لا يلتجئوا الى الى السفر ويلقوا بانفسهم
في المياه وربما والاغلب منهم يموت وهو
يحاول الوصول الى شواطئ الايطاليه او
الفرنسيه لذلك
يعقوبي سيد مراد اذا هو اتفاق يستفيد منه
الجميع اليس كذلك
اولا شكرا على الدعوه مره اخرى يلجا
الكثيرون الى كما يقال تعويم الحوت هذا
صحيح يعني عندما نتامل ما قالته
نلاحظ ان تقريبا هناك اعاده لنفس الكلام
يعني صحيح انه الان وقع تفصيل جمله
الاعانات التي ستقدم الى تونس وهي اكثر
بقليل من 900 مليون يورو ولكن عندما نرى
محتوى هذه الاعانات
اوروبا عندما الحديث عن دفع المبادلات
فهذا طبعا فيه مصحه لاوروبا عندما يقع
الحديث عن الاقتصاد الاخضر وعلى الكابل
البحري الذي تونس بايطاليا والذي ستبلغ
مساعدات فيه 300 مليون اورو
اوروبا لانها بحاجه الى ذلك الرد اما
الهجره
مثلا
يعني الوزير رئيس الحكومه الهولندي كان
واضحا حول مساله الهجره والتي تشمل حددها
قال تشمل البحث والنجده واداره الحدود
وهذا امر خطير عندما نقول اداره الحدود اي
ان اداره الحدود بين الدول الاوروبيه
والدول الاخرى المتعاونه معها والتي ستقوم
بمراقبه الحدود ستكون ادارتها مشتركه وهذا
قيل سابقا وبالتالي هذا هنا يعني هذا هو
الخطر الحقيقه ان هناك
تاكيد لدور دول الهامش في ان تصبح مراقبه
للحدود يعني
سيد مراد امام المشاهد التي نراها
كما قال السيد احمد الهمام امام المشاهد
لالاف المهاجرين غير الشرعيين الذين
يذهبون في البحر ويتركون لمصيرهم بعضهم
والكثير منهم يموت في البحر بهذا الشكل ما
كانت البدائل امام تونس او غير تونس
طبعا
يعني موجوده البدائل ان تكون لك سياده
حقيقيه ان يكون تسيرك لدوتك تسيير ناجح ان
تضمن نموها وان تجعلها في غنى عن الاعانات
الدوليه وفي غنى عن اي مساعده خارجيه وهذا
غير موجود وبالتالي تضطر هذه الدول تونس
او غيرها الى الاستعانه والى اللجوء والى
يعني التقرب اكثر ما يمكن من الصناديق
التمويل الدوليه ومن البحث عن الدعم
الخارجي لانها في الحقيقه تعاني تخفطا
داخليا ليس هناك تحكم او حكمه في التسيير
الداخلي البلاد وبديل البديل كان سيكون
اللجوء الى صندوق النقد الدولي وكلنا نعرف
ان هناك تعثر في مفاوضات مع صندوق النقد
الدولي هذا الاتفاق الذي جرى اليوم بهذه
المعونات الاقتصاديه التي يوفرها لتونس
الا يشكل بديلا افضل خصوصا انه يجنب تونس
الرزوح تحت شروط صندوق النقد
يا سيدتي جزء من هذه الاعانات هي لمصلحه
اوروبا وحتى بالنسبه الى الاعانات التي
وقعت التحدث فيها عن تونس مساله اعانه 80
مدرسه او شيء من هذا القبيل مساله قبول
الطلبه فبرنامج ايراز موسى الذي تحدثه عنه
يعني وقع رصد بين 21 وسنه 27 26
مليار ستحصل منها تونس على مليون اورو ثم
هذا البرنامج قديم وليس جديد هناك تكرار
لنفس التعاون الاوروبي التونسي وليس هناك
اضافه حقيقيه وفعليه وبالمقابل هناك نوع
من التعبئه
والمخاتله حول الدور التونسي في هذا الان
ستصبح تونس مثل العديد من دول العالم
يعني في خدمه اوروبا طيب سيد احمد الهمامي
الم تعلم التجارب ان الغرب عاده عندما
يبرم هكذا اتفاقات تكون كلها في مصلحته
الم يكن بالامكان التوصل الى شروط افضل
لتونس
شكرا لك مره اخرى لكن تفاعلا واجابه على
سؤالك لحد هذه الساعه لم يصدر بلاغا على
الجمهوريه يوضح ما فيها الاتفاقيات ولكن
نحن لدينا بعض المعلومات من هنا وهناك فقط
هل نريد ان ناخذ من اوروبا كل شيء دون ان
نعطيهم شيء هذا اتفاق وهناك شراكه بيننا
وبين دول الاوروبيه شارك تاريخيه شاركه
قديمه ولابد ان تكون مبنيه على المصالح
المشتركه لابد ان تكون مبنيه عن مصالح اذا
لن
نتعا اننا اعلى منها او اقوى منها وه
نا مع بعض هناك اتفاقات تربط
في تونس ليس لو سمحت الان الان بعد ان
يدخل هذا الاتفاق حيز التنفيذ ما مصير
المهاجرين الذين وصلوا الى تونس وراينا في
الايام والاسابيع الماضيه المئات ان لم
يكن الالاف يفترشون الطرق في صفاقس
طبعا هو هنا هذا هذا ما تحدث فيه اليوم في
هذا الاجتماع في طريقه ترحيل
المقيمين في تونس الذي هما يعتبرون تونس
بلد عبور هناك اتفاق الاتفاق فيه كعيد
النقاط يخص الهجره ويخص كيفيه ترحيل
ترحيلهم الى بلد المنشا وكيفيه ومن سيتكفل
بذلك
ببنود معناها في في تفاهم
لانه تونس متضرره اولا والتي الاوروبي
متضرر ثانيا واول من متضرر هي ايطاليا
لانها اقرب دوله الى تونس بحريه لذلك
النسيين يطالبون بترحيل هل الافارقه من
جنوب الصحراوي في الاخر نحن افارقه ولكن
ليس لابد كما قال
رئيس
وجود تنقلهم من بلدان المنشئ الى بلدان
ومن شمال افريقيا شكرا لك احمد الهمامي
المتحدث الرسمي باسم تحالف احرار وشكرا
للسيد مراد اليعقوبي الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي من تونس
[موسيقى]
استقبل رئيس مجلس الوزراء القطري وزير
الخارجيه وزير الخارجيه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن بن جاسم ال ثاني نائبه رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن
الصفدي وجرى خلال اللقاء استعراض علاقات
التعاون الثنائي بين دوله قطر والاردن لا
سيما في المجالات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
والاستثماريه كما اتفق الجانبان على عقد
اللجنه العليا المشتركه بين البلدين قبل
نهايه العام الجاري لتعزيز التعاون بين
البلدين واكد الطرفان مواصله التنسيق في
القضايا ذات الاهتمام المشترك خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وضروره
تحقيق التهدئه واعاده اطلاق مفاوضات جاده
وفاعله لتحقيق السلام العادل والشامل على
اساس حل الدولتين ووفق المرجعيات المعتمده
في اليمن تتزايد معاناه الاطفال مع
استمرار الحرب التي تدخل عامها التاسع
وقالت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
اليونيسف ان سته ملايين طفل على حافه
المجاعه ما يتطلب اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لتوفير المساعدات الانسانيه ياتي ذلك في
وقت تقتض فيه مخيمات النازحين باكثر من
مليونير طفل
اتوا بطفلهم مسرعين بعد قطع مسافه طويله
لتلقي العلاج في مركز التغذيه بتعز يبلغ
من العمر 10 اشهر ويعاني من سوء التغذيه
كحال ملايين الاطفال في اليمن اسرته فقيره
جدا وحليب امه لا يكفي كونها هي الاخرى لا
تحصل على تغذيه جيده اما الحليب الصناعي
فقد صار الحصول عليه من الامان لدى معظم
الاسر اليمنيه
الطفل يعني منذ الولاده وهو في الحضانه
يعني في الحضانه نقلنا بمشقها زايده وجلس
يعني اكثر من يوم في البلاد
ونقلنا الصباح ومعنى الاكتاف وصلنا
للمستشفى الحضانه وجلسناه اكثر من شهر
ولن استطيع الصعوبات واخذناها قالوا انه
الطفله جنى عمرها عام ونصف تعاني ايضا من
سوء تغذيه حاد نجح اهلها من الحديده الى
تعز مضى اسبوع على وجودها في المستشفى لكن
حالتها لم تتحسن بعد وزنها اقل من خمسه
كيلو جرامات عجز اهلها الفقراء عن اسعافها
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله قالت ان
ملايين الاطفال اليمنيين يواجهون مخاطر
متزايده جراء سوء التغذيه وان من بين احد
عشر مليون طفل يحتاجون الى مساعدات
انسانيه يعاني اكثر من 500 واربعين الف
طفل دون سن الخامسه من سوء تغذيه حاد
سوء التغذيه موجود من زمان يعني من قبل
الحصول الحرب هذا ولكن المشكله ان العدد
زي الاكثر والاكثر والمشاكل اكثر والفقر
زاد اكثر الحصار زاد شو كمان بحيث ان حتى
بعض الاطفال يموتوا في البيوت لانه
الاطفال غير قادرين ان يفيدوا الينا
للمستشفى بسبب عدم وجود الماده
تسببت الحرب التي تدخل عامها التاسع في
تدهور الخدمات الطبيه بالبلاد فالمنشات
الصحيه تعرضت لتدمير كلي او جزئي وسيؤدي
ضعف تمويل قطاع الصحه في اليمن الى تضرر
اكثر من الف مرفق صحي وعدم حصول عشره
ملايين شخص بينهم ثمانيه ملايين طفل على
الخدمات الصحيه الضروريه
[موسيقى]
هي محطتنا في فقره المتابعه لحصاد الليله
على ضوء اتهام اذربيجان لروسيا بعدم
الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاق السلام
الذي رعته في المنطقه قبل نحو ثلاثه اعوام
منطقه كاراباخ التي تقطنها اغلبيه ارمانيه
تقدر بنحو 120 الف نسمه لكنها باعتراف
دوليه جزء من اذربيجان تشهد منذ عقدين
نزاع بين البلدين المتجاورين اشعل حربين
بينهما في خريف عام 2020 رعت موسكو اتفاقا
لوقف اطلاق النار على اثر حرب بين باكو
وريفان استمرت سته اسابيع وافضت الى هزيمه
القوات الاربانيه التي اضطرت للتخلي عن
اراضي كانت خاضعه للسيطرتها تعهدت روسيا
حينها بنشر قوات لضمان حريه التنقل بين
ارمينيا وكراباخ عبر طريق الوحيد الذي
يربط بين الجانبين ويسمى ممر لكن
تتهم الان روسيا بعدم الوفاء بالتزاماتها
بموجب اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار وتقول انها
لم تمنع تسليم ارمينيا معدات عسكريه لما
سمتها القوات الانفصاليه في منطقه كندا
روسيا من جانبها تعتبر ان قرار ارمينيا
الاعتراف باقليم كرافاخ كجزء من اذربيجان
ادى الى تغيير جذري في شروط نشر وحده حظ
السلام الروسيه في المنطقه
مع تزايد الانخراط الغربي في جهود احلال
السلام في منطقه كراباخ تحاول موسكو
استعاده زمام المبادره على الصعيد عمليه
السلام هناك وقد عرض الروس اخيرا استضافه
قمه اذربيجانيه ارمينيه في موسكو تفضي
لتوقيع معاهده سلام على اساس الاتفاقات
السابقه بين باكو وياريفان الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي اجتمع السبت في بروكسل مع
القيادتين الارمنيه والاذربيجانيه طالب
الطرفين بالاحجام عن العنف والتصريحات
الحاده اما واشنطن التي استضافت لقاءات
حول كاراباخ على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
الصيف الماضي فدعت اذربيجان لضمان حريه
التنقل عبر المعبر الوحيد الذي يربط
ارمينيا بالمنطقه محل النساء
حول هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من لندن
الدكتوره تمارا دراجاتزي الاكاديميه
والباحثه المتخصصه في شؤون القوقاز دكتوره
تمارا في ظل هذه الاتهامات الاذربيجانيه
ما هو مصير اي مفاوضات سلام حاليا بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا حول كراباخ
اعتقد ان من الصعوبه بمكان الشعور
بالتفاؤل والسبب لان هذه القضيه لها تاريخ
سحيق يتجاوز
الضربه جان وارمينيا ويشمل جورجيا
وافخاسيه وغيرها من هذه الاماكن كلها ان
يتكرروا النمط نفسه والذي يقوم على اساس
ان روسيا تقبل بتقديم ضمانات من اجل
السلام
وتقطع
وعودا
لضمان تحسين العلاقات بين شعبين او بلدين
ولكن لا شيء يحدث من ذلك والسبب في ذلك هو
ان روسيا بالطبع لديها جيش موجود في
قرابات وفي قاعدتين في جورجيا نتحدث عن
قرباخ ونتحدث
ايضا عن كون روسيا قلقه لو انه طلب اليها
ان تطلب من سحب قواتها لانه اذا كانت هناك
حاله من السلام ولم يعد هناك حاجه لاي
ضمانات هذا سيكون مصدر قلق لروسيا لانه
تحتاجه الى ان يكون لها وجود في القوقاز
لهذا السبب هي تقوم بنفس الشيء وهو ان
تشعر الشعوب المعنيه بضروره استمرار وجود
الروس لانه من دونهم لن يكون هناك سلام
واجب ان يظهر الروس وكانهم
يفعلون ما هو ما هو لازم الوجود الروسي في
القوقاز وفي هذه المنطقه هو مرهون فقط
باستمرار هذا الخلاف وهذا الصراع حول
كاراباخت من وجهه نظرك
نعم اعتقد انه من حيث ان
هناك حاجه لان يكون هناك حضور ووجود
لروسيا هناك هو الشعور بان هناك مشكلات
حوالي اقليمي
بالطبع لهذا السبب هذا امر ينبغي ان يدرك
لانه في خاتمه المطاف عندما يكون هناك
اسلوب تفكير مختلف في روسيا قد لا تشعر
روسيا بانه لا حاجه لها للبقاء وتغادر لكن
اليوم بالطريقه التي تتم فيها
التفكير السياسي واسلوب التعامل روسيا
وتوجهات روسيا هو المحافظه على وجود لها
في اقاليم القوقاز وليس فقط طبعا تحديدا
في اذربيجان للابقاء على هذا الوجود اشكرك
من لندن دكتوره تمارا دراجزاني او
دراجاتزي الاكاديميه والباحثه المتخصصه في
شؤون القوقاز شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
صحيح ان الستار اسدل على منافسات بطوله
ويمبلدان للتنس لكنها ستظل عالقه في اذهان
الملايين خصوصا في منطقتنا العربيه والسر
هو التونسيه انس جابر نجمه التنس العالميه
خسرت انس في النهائي لكن كلماتها وتاثرها
حذاء اعجاب كثيرين هذه اكثر خساره مؤلمه
في مسيرتي لكنني لن استسلم وساعود اقوى
انها رحله صعبه لكني اعدكم بالعوده وسافوز
بلقب هذه البطوله يوما ما هذا مقالته انس
وهي تقاوم دموعها في تونس تعد اللاعب رمزا
وطنيا وتلقب بوزيره السعاده وهي مصدر
الهام لكثير من الفتيات في منطقه تعد فيها
كره القدم الرياضه الاكثر شعبيه والامر لا
يتعلق فقط بمهارتها بل بكونها منتج تونسي
مئه في المئه والامر يتعلق ايضا بمثابرتها
وقدرتها على التغلب على سلسله من الاصابات
وقربها من المعجبين حظا اوفر انس في المره
القادمه بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد نشكر
لكم متابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]